サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今年は大変幸福な年でありますようにと
新年の祝い 祝福を申し上げます
このブッダの教えを学ぶ方々は
特別にお守りやら神社仏閣に行ってお願いすることがなくても
慈悲の瞑想を朝晩やれば
自分の心からものすごく素晴らしい波動が宇宙に広がります
それによって 誰にも何の不幸も
何の問題も起きません
だから自分の慈悲が自分をしっかりと守ってくれます
そういうわけで 毎日幸福で幸せで
慈悲の実践の御加護で生きていられると思いますから
常にそれも覚えておいてください
えーと 今日の法話のお布施がございまして
前田真理子さんが今日の法話会のお布施をいただきいたしまして
特に自分のお母様により元気になって幸せになってほしいという希望もあります
で お母様がなんか大変介護で父親の介護で結構苦労していたみたいし
ですから 介護っていうのはものすごい重労働でしょうしね
ですから 真理子さんのお母さん
ますます元気で明るく
精神的にしっかり強く生活できますようにと祈願いたします
それから 真理子さんと家族の皆様方に
このお布施の法施のね
功徳によって一切の幸せが訪れますように
心が清らかになりますように
涅槃に解脱に達することの糧になりますようにと祝福いたします
皆様 サーデュサーデュサーデュ
はい あの 今日はとても寒い日になりましてね
その上であまりも冷えてしまうテーマにもなりまして
とにかく凍らないように気をつけてください
話を聞いて えーと これ随所というんですかね
随所 主となるという 正直なところは
何の意味か私はわかりません
これは仏教と言ったっても
日本の仏教から  中国です
中国の  中国のね はいいんだけど
この中国の意味を調べたんだけど
なんか変な意味になるんですね
それで日本語でって言ったら
またすごく英語で調べると
もうなんかわけのわからない意味になっちゃうんですね
じゃあまあ 私は私なりに話していきます
まず この主となるということは
まあ自分自身が物事の主人公になることなんですね
まあ誰だってそうなりたいとは思っているでしょうね
人に言われたままできるよりは
自分が言う通りにみんな合わせてくれれば
それはありがたいことなんですね
それでこの主人公というこの言葉を理解していきましょう
別に辞書の言葉ではなくて
現実的な世界でどうやって使えるものかとかね
例えば日中はもう太陽は主人公なんですね
太陽があるからデーターと英語で言うんですね
だからデイというのは結局は太陽の使う単語になるんですね
夜は英語だったらナイトですからね
まあナイトっていうのはおそらくノーライトでしょうね
それで太陽は主人公だから
私たちは自分の人生はそれに合わせる
植物を太陽に合わせる
この主役っていうのはそういうものなんですね
しかし 面白いことは 太陽が我々に指令したり
管理したり あんた方はそうしなさいと言ってるわけじゃないんです
太陽は何も信号を出してないよ
植物というのはちゃんと太陽の方を向かって伸びなさいとかね
それは私たちが 動植物たちが素直に従っているんです
なんで素直に従っているのかというと
この太陽からそれぐらいの我々は恩恵を受けているんですね
だから本物の主人は物質世界では地球ではね
太陽なんです 何も文句は言えない
我々を管理しようともしない
ですから 私たちは自分の意思で太陽に従うんですね
だから全然ストレスもかかりませんし
気付きもない というわけで
太陽が動植物の人生を導いているんですね
だから指令しないんだから
私は優しいという言葉を使いたかったんだけど
なんか怪しいんですね
太陽は優しいかどうかよくわからない
なぜならば 太陽のせいでね
結構ひどい目に遭う時もありますからね
太陽のせいでもないんだけど
これ地球関係ですからね
じゃあお正月って言ったらどうですかね
お正月は基準になると
私たちは自分の行動をそれに合わせます
お正月というたった 1 日があるんですね
まあ時々ちょっと戦後も使いますけどね
それで我々の生き方は
我々はそれに合わせて
お正月という概念に導かれて生きているんですね
その何日かは 結婚披露宴で新郎新婦が主人公になるんです
はい ここでちょっと勉強しましょう
結婚披露宴では一番メインキャラは新郎新婦でしょ
変でしょ あの二人は猿のように周りのしきたり習慣に回されているだけです
んですね なんか主人公なんですけど
プログラム通りの動かなくちゃいけなくなってるんですね
だからどこまで自分が主人公として人を何か影響を与えるかっていうことはよくわからないね
この場合は そのようにたまたま主人公になる場合はあるんだけどね
それっていろいろバラバラなんですね
映画などではちゃんと主役があるんですね
そこで一番惨めなのが主役なんですよ
ディレクターの言いたい放題に自分が演出しなくちゃいけないんだからね
主人公にするのは編集の時なんですね
だからディレクターがその映画の場合はね
主人公なんですね ディレクターが自分が伝えたいストーリーを
あの人々を道具として使って発表しているんですね
しかし 私たちはそのディレクターのね
監督の名前以外は大してスクリーンには出ませんね
そういう主人公もいますね
それからまたいろんないますよ
国王 王政の時 今はないんだけどね
国王 フランスとかね 王政の時
それから独裁者っていうね
北朝鮮みたいな将軍とかね
あの連中も主人公で みんなその時は無理やり抑えているんですね
人々 だから結局は人々を搾取する
人々にダメージを与える
人々に迷惑をかける 人々を支配する
あの気持ち悪い連中も結局は主人公なんです
ですから 我々はどんな主人公になりたいんですかね？なんか結構複雑ですね
単純じゃないんです そこでついでに仏教の一言葉を言うんだけど
釈尊が生命に対して太陽のごとくのリーダーであると
だから釈尊もいろんな名前をたくさんつけてありますね
尊称というね 一つはまあ
太陽という言葉なんですね
アーディッチバンドというんですね
アーディッチというのは太陽
バンドっていうのは親族というね
だから太陽の親族関係というね
太陽そのものだとは言わない
まあ言ってる場合もありますけどね
だからその場合は 太陽は満遍なくすべての動植物に明かりと暖かさを与えている
完全無差別ですね 差別しない
区別しない だから我々は慈悲の実践する時でも
その太陽のような心で
一切生命に何の制限もなく
何の区別もなく 慈しみの気持ちを抱きなさいと
広げなさいとも言っているんですね
でお釈迦様はだいたいそういう風な感じの主人公なんですね
だから人を管理しません
いかなる場合でも人に迷惑をかけません
しかし お釈迦様からお釈迦様のおかげで
どんな生命にも幸せになることが可能です
お釈迦様はこの食事を終わって
この鉢で丸い鉢があります
そこで食事をいただいていたんですけど
それでそれを洗って水を捨てる時でも
周り 草とか植物 生きてる植物ないところを見て
またいろんな生命たちがうろうろしてないところを見て
丁寧に水を土に戻すんだと
そこまで気をつけるんです
迷惑をかけないようにと
はい そのようにこの世の中でありがたい主人公もいて
全然ありがたくない まあ潰してやりたい主人公たちもいる
親は子供の場合は支配者ですけどもね
子供の立場から見れば
ある時は親がありがたくてしょうがないし
ある時はうるさくてたまらないしね
いろいろ変わったりする
子供が親がうるさいと言って家出して独立する
一人暮らしする場合は
もう怒って出て行くんですね
なぜならば この親がなんとなくずっと子供を管理しようとはするんですね
なんとなく まあ大人だからやめましょうということをちょっとできないんですね
ずっと慈しんで育てましたから
どうしても子供のことを心配してしまう
だから それで弱みになっちゃって
子供のことを心配するからこそ
子供に怒られて節制になるということもありますね
だからそこら辺で人間だからね
正しくない態度をとるんですね
だから独立していくと
自由に話してあげることも管理者の責任なんですね
卒業しているのに 学校に毎日来なさいというのはね
変ですね だから親に仏教ではこの最初の師匠というんですね
あのプッバーチャリアーティウッチャレ
ファーストティーチャーズ
ベーシックティーチャー
だから最初にすべて子供たちが親から学ぶんだから
親でありながら師匠でもあるんですね
だから さっさと親の役柄から師匠の役柄に変わるならば
師匠は生徒が卒業したら
はい さようなら 元気で頑張ってね
で 終わり だからブッダの言葉を聞くならば
どんな家族も不幸にならないんです
親子喧嘩は絶対成り立たないんです
それで親と子供の優しい関係
ずっと続くんです その場合は
親が亡くなっても 子供は親のことをずっと感謝して生活するようになるんですね
だから 仏教を知らない人々はものすごい損しているんです
わがままで執着で 損するんですね
とにかくそうやっていろんな主人公たちがいることを理解しましょう
そこで人生の主人公は曖昧
そこで人生っていうのは自分の人生ですね
はい こう考えます 私の人生の主人公は何ですか？と
当然自分でしょ では 自分がしっかりした主人公ですかね
自分の人生の主になってますかね
変じゃない そこを曖昧なんですね
言わなくたっても 誰の人生の
主人公は主役は自分自身なんです
周りにはどうすることもできません
人の代わりに寝てあげるとか
人の代わりに食べてあげるとか
できっこはないでしょう
人の代わりに勉強してあげるとか
人の代わりに結婚してあげるとか
人の代わりに子供を作ってあげるとか
何もできないでしょうね
だから他人にできるのはわずかな協力なんですね
その人は自分の意思で考えて相手を選んだら
周りは結婚式してあげましょうと
その程度の協力はできますけど
だから実際 自分の人生の主人公
主役は自分自身であって
これはもう変えることは絶対できません
これを忘れているんですね
人間は 曖昧というか変ですね
自分の人生を自分が好きなようにと謳ってはいるが
実際どのように生きるべきか誰もわかりません
偉そうに言うでしょ？俺の人生は俺のやりたいようにやっていますよと
口を挟むなよとね 偉そうに言うだけ
そういう人に限ってすごく変です
何もできないんです 生命は他の無数の原因に依存して惨めに生かされている存在です
結局は自分自身が主人公なのに
主役なのに惨めで生かされているんです
あの この日本語で考えると生かされている
ありがたいなということではないんです
あれは迷信であって こちらは客観的に生かされているということは惨めなんです
あの養殖場で魚飼っているでしょ
あんな感じです あのニワトリ
チキンファームあるでしょ？ニワトリ飼っているでしょ
ニワトリたちが ありがたい？生かされているだけでしょう
身動きもできないし 豚を飼っていると
豚っていうのはかなり激しく動く動物ですけど
肉が硬くなるんだから動かせないんですね
檻に入れて で ちゃんと餌もらいますよ
餌探しに苦労しなくてする必要もないし
体に虫がついたら虫で悩む必要もないし
ほとんど無菌状態の豚小屋で育てられますけど
惨めでしょ だから生かされているという言葉がね
論理的に見ると あんまりにも惨めなんです
要するに 自分には何もできないということになるんです
だから人間もね 養殖場で飼っている魚のようなもんでしょ
自由 独立とは 依存している原因を別な原因に変えて依存を変えることだけです
そこで人間がたまたま自由を目指して頑張ろうとかね
独立を目指して頑張ろうとくだらんことを言っていて
例えば  年 年かな ね もっと前ね
年って言ったっけ？戦争終わって
戦争終わってから私が生まれたんだから
年ですね で 帝国 日本帝国
一般国民には何の自由もなかったんです
政府は国民のことでやりたい放題
今はもうアメリカ 西洋式なりに自由ですね
民主主義国家で何言ってるんですかね
ただ別なものに依存しているだけでしょ
今も公の人々のあのでっかい態度どうですかね
役所なんかに行ったら
我々は依存を変えるだけ
例えば 若い子たちが仕事を見つけて社会人になって
まだ親のところにいると
それで親も本人もね なんだろうことは言わずにね
親のご飯食べてこちらにいるのはね
やっぱり独立しなくちゃいかんやと思って
どうする？どこかの女を探して結婚するんですよ
で これで自由になった
だから親に管理されているあの依存をやめて
別なグループに管理されている
もう依存変えただけ 人間変ですよ
その点で自由になれないね
いろんな国々で革命起きるでしょ
あの昔ね あの中国の共産党の革命があって
ロシアのね また一番最初ロシアで革命があって
この支配されて搾取されて
ツァールという王ですね
あの連中に支配されて
なんてけしからんやと言って戦って
人殺して革命を起こして
スターリンという独裁者の下にまたひどい目に遭う羽目になっちゃうね
なんだこりゃと それからレニンとかね
だから労働者はずっと労働者のままで何も変わってない
ただ ツァールと王家の貴族系は殺しましたから
その代わりに何かのグループが入り込んだだけ
現在 ロシアはどうですかね
何人かしか金持ちじゃないんです
全部国のロシアのね オリガルヒって言うんですね
何人かに支配して管理しているという
時々悪口を言ってます
プーチンの 対策はもう一度ツァールのシステムに戻ることやと
だからかわいそうでしょ
人間が自由になれない
アジアの国々どうですかね
民主主義だと言い張っているんだけど
インドは世界で一番大きい民主主義国家でしょ
何人が金持ちに？管理されているだけ
何のこともないんで だから私は今仏教の話をしてますよ
だから仏教から見れば
あんた方はね 嘘を言うなよと
イカれた言葉を言うなよと
自由だ 独立しているんだとかね
人権がある んだとかね
いい加減にしろ 命の尊厳
嘘ばっかし 命の尊厳 人間のこのヒューマンライツとか言ってるわりに
特にヒューマンライツの場合は
イギリスとかね ヨーロッパのうるさいんですね
あの人たち へっちゃらで他のアジアの国々をバカにしているんですね
いろんな政府を壊そうと
このヒューマンライツという人権という鉄砲を持ってきて
何のこともないんです
バカでないけど 人間言うことは信じる必要はないんです
思想家とか哲学者とか宗教家とかね
政治家とかね アホなら信じてください
カモにされるだけ あなた方の自由は何かしら奪うだけ
例えば日本ではね じゃあ日本に限って喋りましょう
皆様はいろんな悩みがある
いろんな問題を抱えている
病人が家族に出てくるわ
いろんな収入が足らないわ
仕事は大変でしょうし
もうハチャメチャ苦労するし
あるいはもう一人の親で子育てなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうし
これはあんまりも悩んじゃうと
まあ心の安らぎやと思って
何か宗教組織に入る どうですかね
バカにされるだけでしょう
そちらの偉い開祖様とかね
偉い神様っていう連中がいるんです
性格は最低くだらないんだけどね
そちらを拝まなくちゃいけないんです
それよりは自分飼ってる犬を拝んだ方がいいんでしょうに
犬は何も今尾っぽ振ってくれるしね
体に飛んでくるしね 楽しいでしょ
犬を拝むと犬は顔を舐めてくれるしね
別に犬のよだれがね まああまり好きじゃないんだけど
別に気持ち悪いわけでもないんですね
愛されてるっていう感じがあるんだから
犬に はい そういうわけで
この主人公っていうのは曖昧っていうことをはっきり理解しましょう
人の今の知識 能力では
自ら自由の主人公になることはできません
我々の頭に 心に問題があるんです
思考パターンに問題があるんです
で どのように考えるかっていうことは
この赤ちゃんちゃんの時からじわじわじわじわ学ぶでしょ
価値観はお母さんお父さんが教えてくれるし
学校の教師が教えてくれるし
だから最初から依存するステージから始まるんですよ
だからベースは基礎は依存する基礎なんです
その上に知識を重ねて重ねて重ねていっても
実験してしていっても
ファウンデーションは
依存なんです ですから
人間に自由になることは無理です
それはちょっと過言ですが
理解するために覚えておいてください
無理です 何か考えても
借りた概念で借りた思考方法で考えてるでしょ
自分 独立的な思考じゃないでしょ
皆様よく言うでしょうね
何かやっぱり世の中みんなそう思ってるんだよと
あんたやってることは常識はおかしいんやと
その一言葉でわかるでしょ？いかに依存しているのかと
常識はずれの考え持って何が悪いの？はい
次に行きましょうか ですから
本来自由 まあ主人公主人公と言ったっても
この独立自由になることなんです
自分のことを自分でやる世界なんです
それがもう自分の力でできない
もう脳に問題があるんです
例えばサッカーやりたい
しかし 足の骨が折っている
broken 無理でしょ
骨が壊れたままでサッカーできるわけないでしょ
だからまずその問題解決しなくちゃいけないんです
それで足 骨を元に戻してリハビリもして
足がしっかり健康になったところで
まあそれからサッカー
サッカーをやろうとすればね
構いませんね だから基本的にこの骨が折れるとか
この脳が壊れてるんだからね
そこを治さなくちゃいけないんです
だから道順がありますね
まれな人に自分自身で道を発見できるかもしれません
自由になる道 まれな人に
見えてくるかもしれません
しかし 現代世界では一人もいないんです
人は自我中心的で主観で感情的に思考するから
自由になりじゃなくて
なる道を自分自身で発見することはできなくなっているんです
これが症状です それは問題です
だからサッカーなどで言えば骨が折れている
足の そこを知ったら そちらに治療しなくちゃいけない
我々人間として惨めで依存して生かされている
養殖場の魚のように だから
なんでそうなったのかと
見た目から見れば 我々は誰かを檻に入れてるわけではないし
皆様その気になれば金さえあれば地球上を回ることもできるし
別になんか問題なさそうに見えますね
勇気あれば仕事を変えて別な仕事に就職することもできるとはできるでしょうしね
だから自由な見せかけはあるんだけど
病気は別なところなので
我々は自我中心 思考するときは私という主語で思考しているんです
主観で 感情的に 何か考えると私というところから主観で自分に見える世界
自分が感じる それから思考
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ あれやこれや
感情でバイアスが入って
スムーズに正しく進んでいないんです
だから自由になる道は発見できない
だから自由っていうのは
私が思う道が自由ではないんです
なぜならば 私の思うこと自体が自由じゃないんだから
こうなりたい ああなりたいと思うことも
世間の情報に依存して現れた考えなんです
それに自分の好み 好き嫌い入れているんです
だから人間考える自由は自由じゃないんです
そういうわけで 自分で発見できないということは確かなんです
他人から教えてもらわなくてはならないという壁があります
結局はそれすら他人から教えてもらわなくちゃいけないんですね
自分に見えない世界 自分に見えないアプローチ
自分が観察しなかったデータ
あれこれと他人から受け入れなくちゃいけないんですね
同じ罠なんですね 今も他人に言われる通りに生きているんだからね
自由じゃないし しかし
自由になろうとしてしたら
また同じことを使わなくちゃいけなくなるんです
はい ということで 他に頼るということがまた問題なんです
絶対的な存在に無批判的に依存するべきという教えは初めからアウトです
ここで皆様方は精神の自由を目指して
地球の人間 皆様方ではなくて
あちらこちら探しているといるんですね
人々は店を開いて 看板を書いて
絶対的な神様にうちの店として信仰しなさいと
いろんな店があるんです
絶対的か唯一の神 それぞれの店で神に名前までつけているんです
それはもう論外 なぜならば
イスラム教であろうが
キリスト教であろうか
ヒンドゥー教もそれなりに揃わせた教であろうか
日本の大乗仏教であろうか
例えば真言密教やらね
浄土系の諸宗教 宗派とかね
誰かに絶対的な存在に依存させようとしているんです
アホじゃない これ自由になれないんですよね
神のしもべになって なんだこれはと
だから自由な世界の場合は
誰かに依存しておねだりする
お願いする 念仏を唱える
いい加減やめなさい そんなのは
初めからの論理が合ってないんです
阿弥陀さんいう人が救ってくれるんだ
お前をとかね 矛盾です
そのためには死ななくちゃあかんでしょ？なんたる悪ですかね
阿弥陀さんが 死ぬ前に救ってくれよと
そうすると実感できるんだから
早く死んでくれと 矛盾でしょ
自由になるために師匠
これ インドではこのグルという偉い概念があるんですね
それからティベット密教
仏教でもグルというのはかなり大事な壁です
ね 依存してグルを信仰するべきだという教えも
完璧アウトではなくて危険です
絶対的神はもう完璧アウト
話にならない 見てください
世の中で絶対的神を信仰する人はどれぐらいいるんですかね？どれぐらい人間でない人間がいるのかということでしょう
まあグルっていうのはそんなに大げさな存在ではないんですけど
だからそれでもグルに依存しなくちゃあかんだから
特にティベット仏教っていうのは
この一神教と同じくかなり商売には
すごく気になるんですね
だから誰かのグルになったら
輪廻転生しても その人は自分のグルなんで変えられません
かなり昔 私はマレーシアでちょこっとした何かやっている時
あるアメリカ人のかなり知識人なんですけど
女の人が来たんですね
お寺にいたんだからね
で この人がまあ私はうろうろやることがなくなってると
もう話しかけてきて 自分も仏教と
ああそう って 私は別に興味ないんだからね
私は仏教徒だからといってね
どうでもいいんで 私には
そこでどんな仏教って言ったら
チベット仏教で 自分が自分はこの輪廻過去生でも仏教徒で
あのグルがいたんだと
今そのグルがなんとかリンポチェ
なんとかなんとかと で
で 自分がその人を尊敬して
その人の指導を受けて修行しているんだと
で 写真見せるんですよ
子供なんです まだちっちゃな子供で
チベット仏教でも子供ではもう二十歳ぐらいにならなきゃ
一人前のラーマになりませんよ
あの商売するために この過去でリンポチェが死んじゃって生まれ変わったと
生まれ変わってもリンポチェはリンポチェだと
あまりにも密教なんです
生まれ変わったら新しい人間でしょうに
最初から学ばなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だから私はもう この女たちが偉そうに世界を支配して
我々にもガチャガチャガチャガチャアジア人に悪口を悪に
もうこの獣やと この人は
何の恥も感じないんですね
四歳ぐらいの赤ちゃんを椅子に座らせて写真撮って拝んでるんだから
あの赤ちゃんに何ができるんですかね
だからこのグルという概念自体は悪くないんです
でもちょっと進んじゃうと危険なところがあります
だって皆様にも私にもグルがいるでしょうに
別に悪くないでしょうに
私は自分自身で発見したもの
喋っているわけじゃないでしょ？皆様も自分自身で発見した知識で生きているわけないでしょ
だから先生たちは 講師たちは先輩たちがいろいろ教えてくれたんだからね
グルがいるんでしょうに
だからグルという概念は
あの英語でグルというと
ちょっと変な意味になるんです
普通は言語で インド語でパーリ語でグルというのはティーチャーなんですね
ティーチャーは優しい存在なんです
今 グルという単語を英語でも使っても
その場合は俺の話し聞け
批判するなよという態度の師匠のことをグルと言うんですね
はい 師匠 指導者が必要ですが
その師匠が自由を獲得している智慧の達人でなければいけません
師匠は信頼できないと
だから師匠が自由になっている
師匠には智慧がある 智慧の達人だったら
弟子にした方がいいんです
はい こういう風に仏教的にみんな言うから飛んでいくんじゃなくて
ちゃんと調べた方がいいということになるんです
まず人は師匠の資格を調べるべきです
だから世の中でそんなバチが当たるんだとかね
いいんです バチが当たっても
この開祖様たちが本当に何か知っているのかどうかね
最近ある人が来てね あんた日蓮様ってどう思います？ブッダで悟ってるんだと言うんですけど
腹が立ちまったけどね
自分で調べなさいと 私は調べたら
日蓮というのはただのおっさんでね
もう何の能力もない人なんです
私は日本で尊敬するのは
まあ道元禅師ぐらい 禅師たちが結構立派な人間はいるんだけどね
他みんなもう ただのおっさんたちですよね
喋っている 書いているものを読んでみてもね
何のこともない だから今日のテーマのタイトルになったのも
やっぱりこれ禅宗の誰かの言葉でしょ
あの言葉は単純じゃない
これから私は解説していきますけどね
面白いことは 禅宗のお坊さんたちに
自分たちの師匠たちが言っている言葉の意味がわからないんです
この公案とか解読できないんです
私も何でもそういうのはね
さっさと解読しますが
ちょっと道がちょっと険しいんだから
ちょっと簡単 聞く人に簡単じゃない
私にとっては単純簡単ですけどね
はい それで仏教に戻りましょう
仏陀は偉大なる師匠なんです
信じなさいではないんです
ブッダ自身が私を調べなさいと言うんです
なぜなら 私が正統学者であると
真理を発見しているんだと
悟っているんだと公に言っているんだと
だから あんた方 この言葉は本当か嘘か
詐欺師か調べなさいよと
それで助けてあげるんです
どうせあんた方には超一流の知識能力ないんだから
私を調べる場合は あんた方にこんな範囲で調べることできますよと
調べる いわゆるそういう技まで教えてあげるんです
どうだい？こういうところをチェックしなさいと
人を導くためのブッダの資格は明確に発表しています
だから仏典を読んでみると
うるさいほどお釈迦様の資格を最初に出すんです
皆様方 何か知識を得るために本を買う場合は
本の後を見るでしょう
あの本を書いたライターの資格は何なのかと
例えば脳科学の本ででっかい脳科学
大体日本人なんて全てがわかる本ばっかり書くんだからね
全てわかる本で 私は後ろを見ると
そこら辺のおっさんですね
結局は 普通どこかで大学で誰だって大学卒業するんだからね
ではなくて 時々本見ると
こんな大学で MD 取って
こんな研究所でこれぐらい研究して
アメリカのなんだらかんだらの大学で
なんだらかんだらのところで
なんだらかんだらの研究所で
こういう風なことをやってるんだと言ったら
もう例えばまあ五 六年このテーマにあってね
これぐらい発表しているんだとかね
とあると なんとなくあの本読んで読んで
そのデータが信頼できるんだということになるでしょ
それでも私は批判的に読むんです
いくらタイトルがでっかくても
そういうわけで 仏教も同じスタンスで
まずブッダ自身の資格を出しています
皆様知ってる？それは知らないんだけど
皆様に暗記させているんです
イティピソーバガワっていうのはほとんどの人々覚えてるでしょ
うん イティピソーバガワアラーンサンマワサンブットどうだ？細々それ暗記までさせてるんです
ブッダの資格 指導者として
師匠として まあ一つ二つ説明します
このイティピソーの偈にサッターデーワマヌッサナナンという言葉があるんです
意味は 如来は天人 人間の師匠です
お釈迦様は人間だけの師匠じゃなくて
神々の師匠でもあります
誰にでも教えてあげる
はい そこでちょっと大胆なことを読める人というのは読める
読める 世間では何か神秘体験があったら
何か神のメッセージがあったら
何かどこかの星団 なんとかから何か放射線が当たったとかね
なんだらかんだらくだらんことを言うでしょ
自分に権威を作る 夢で見たんだとかね
ということどういうこと？この世間の愚か者たちが
何かちょっと頭イカれた常識でない何か経験みたいな
こんな変な神秘体験っていうのは
結構人間にごく普通にあるんでしょうね
時々わけもわからない夢を見たりとかね
まあ普通 時々音もないのに何か音を聞こえたりとかね
そこを商売にする だから人類はそういう本当に情けない病気だから
仏教は堂々と ブッダは神の教えを言っているわけじゃないんです
ブッダに神が来て 神に教えたわけじゃないんです
逆 お前にも教えてあげるよ
お前たちにも教えてあげる
はい それで ブッダの話を学ぶ人にとってはしっかり信頼できるということになるんです
ブッダの話を聞こうか
隣のどこかであのゴミ食べて閉会している聖者も
なんか毎日神と交信しているんだから
その人の話を聞こうかなとか
皆様はブッダの話よりは誰か神と交信しているんだったら
そちらに行くでしょ？あれ
特別な言葉もあります
チャネリングとか なんでチャネリングする人はそんなに偉いんですかね？ただの敗走病さでしょ
我々はこの山 何でしたっけ？山
山猫なんとかって挨拶ありますね
それで荷物持ってきたら拝んでありがとうございます
荷物を持ってないでしょうに
反抗してはいどうぞと
私の場合はね 時々水とかね
運んでくれるんだから
それは家の仲間で運んでくれるんだから
私重いしね その場合は特別にありがとうとは言いますけどね
そんなに拝む必要ないでしょうに
それにしたら もうどこかのお化けからチャネリングする人を
もう拝むことどこまであほまでわからないんです
だから仏教は大胆にそこを壊してます
神にも教えてあげるんですということで
だから神にも教えてあげるという意味でもう一つ読めるでしょ
人間のこのハンディ障害を破っているだけじゃなくて
人間いつでも神と交信する人のところに行くんですよ
心理学でも今わかってるでしょ
そういうのは病気であるということは
仏教心理学でなくても
俗世間の誰しないガタガタ心理学でも病名までついています
だから世の中誰だって精神的な病気だったら
その人を神に仕立てて拝むんだからね
あんた方を導く能力ないでしょうに
もともとその人は病気だから
ですから このそこを破っているんだ
仏教はいきなり ブッダは行使して喋っているわけじゃない
神々に教えろと だから
えっと思わなくちゃ そんなすごいことを何言ってるんですか
あなたはというふうに批判的でいいです
自分で調べながら学んでみればよろしいです
次の言葉はアヌットラプリシダンマサーレティ
人を躾けることについて
この上のない存在です
お釈迦様は言うんです
人を解脱ではなくて 自由へ導こうと思ったら
その躾 私に敵う人はいませんと
別に当たり前で だけど誰も自由になっていないんだから
世の中で ブッダが自由を獲得したんだからね
それだけじゃなくて 躾する方法も上手なんですね
いわゆるパーフェクトエデュケーションですなんですね
例えば 世の中で立派な知識人
いくらでもいるでしょ
教えることになっちゃうと
下手で下手で何も教えられない
だから 知識人になる能力と自分の知識を教える時の能力っていうのは同じじゃないんです
勉強できてすごい頭がいいと言っただけで
その人にもう一人人に教えられるかって
また別なんです お釈迦様は両方できます
完全たる悟っているだけではなくて
人に教える場合も誰も敵わないんです
それからサンマサンブッダ
正等覚者であるサンマっていうのはパーフェクト
何も残らず完全という意味なんです
悟ってますと だから知らないものは何もない
それから正確 ヴィッチャーチャラナサンパンの智慧と道徳を完成しています
悟っている言葉と智慧という言葉はダブってないんです
智慧といったら 他の能力もいくつかあるんです
それは悟りに別にあってもなくても構いません
九つぐらいありますけども
お釈迦様には偉大なる智慧は
この道徳の方はこの十五
十五個の句ありますね
なかなかかなわない能力があります
はい そういうわけで ポイントもう一度戻って考えましょう
私たちは自由になりたければ
主人になりたければ あの間違った手段を最初から使わなくちゃいけない
人に聞いてみると それかなりやばいんですね
スタートはそこからなんです
だから人に聞いてみる場合は気をつけましょうと
資格あるかないか調べましょうよと
そこで仏教はこれぐらい資格ありますよと
それは先に教えるんです
そこで じゃあブッダの教えから自由を目指して人は頑張る場合は
お釈迦様はその道がものすごくわかりやすく
つのステージで教えているんです
これは三学と呼んでティシカですね
パーリ語で つの学ぶことがあるんです
これも一 二 三で順番で行かなくちゃいけないんです
だからこのエデュケーションの場合はパーフェクトなんです
ブッダほど完全な教育者っていうのは存在しない
仏教を学んだら もう坊主たち見てください
もうどこでも世界中堂々と喋れる能力があるんです
大した能力を持たせ生まれるんでしょうね
私もそうでしたけどね
仏教を学んだところで
もう怖いものない状態で喋られるんです
だからブッダが師匠からでしょ
ブッダがこの生ゴミにも価値のない生ゴミにする価値のない人間をしっかり育ててみせるんです
いわゆる落ちこぼれはないんです
ブッダの場合は  1番目は
これから皆様はいくらか知っている世界になります
シーラ 道徳のシステム
まず道徳からいかなくちゃいけない
道徳って簡単です 本当のところは
感情に支配されてロボットのように生きることを戒める教えです
だからまずロボットになることをやめなさいと
言うんです それでも相手がよくわからないね
だからこういうこういうふうに五戒守ってみなさい
言った途端 自分の本能は五戒を破りたいんです
どんな生命も嘘をついたいんです
人を侮辱したいんです
人と戦いたいんです 敵を潰したいんです
そういう恐ろしい存在なんです
もともと我々の本能は
だから相手を殺すでも生き延びるということは
遺伝子にまであるんです
しかし 遺伝子プログラムは自分のことを馬鹿にしているということにあまり気づいていないんです
みんなこの科学世界ではね
遺伝子は大事に思っても
遺伝子はあなたの命のことを何とも思ってないんです
自分勝手に動いて壊れていくんです
遺伝子は自分の次のプログラム
遺伝子グループ作れたら
お前はもう用済みと捨てるんです
だから私たちは命かけて子孫を育てる
自分のことはもう二の次にするんです
それより子供のことが大事だと
馬鹿です なぜならば この子供が大人になったら同じことをやるんです
自分の命を二の次にして
次の子孫を作るんです
だから皆様 奴隷にされているでしょう
皆様の遺伝子が与えている指令はたった 1個
子孫を作れと 指令に乗っているだけです
だから 自分の子孫が手がかかる間では親が元気ですよ
何でも頑張れる それで手がかからなくなってきて
子供は独立していくと
自分がぐーっと衰えていくんです
遺伝子ってそんなもんなんです
残酷です 遺伝子そのものもすごくアホなんです
自分が続けていると勘違いしているんです
しかし 遺伝子も瞬間瞬間変わるんです
私が生まれた時もらった遺伝子は今ないんです
いわゆる分解してみたら
いろんなものが変わっているんです
あの基本的な柱が似ているんだから
みんな遺伝子同じ同じやとか言ってるんですけど
違います 事実 すーっと読んでみなくちゃいかんですね
これ かなり膨大な量データがあるんだけど
そうすると 細胞分離するたびに遺伝子が変わって変わっていくんです
だから自分が子孫を作っても
それは自分の遺伝子じゃないんです
でしょ？はっきり出てるでしょ
男と女の遺伝子 半分半分つなげたまるっきり新しいものでしょ
それでも私の子やとね
思うことはもう馬鹿以外何でもないんです
遺伝子に騙されてるんです
はい そういうわけで言いたかったのはこういうこと
我々は敵を殺してでも生き延びたい
子供のことを心配するんだけど
自分の子供を守るために他の子供を殺さなくちゃいけなくなったらやっちゃいます
だから何の道徳にならんね
そんなのは ですから この本能のまま生きるとロボットなんです
だからちょっと戦ってみなさいと
欲が湧いてきても 欲に負けないようにする
例えば 最近の皆様方は結婚しているし
何か自分が頭が何か真っ白くなるような美人が見える
見えちゃうと遺伝子がもうなんて言いますか
燃えちゃって ホルモンが出しちゃって
あの女はなんかしようと
なんとかしてでも あの
自分のものにしなさいと
その時 欲 仏教的に心理学的に欲が生まれているんですね
欲が生まれたから遺伝子が変化してホルモンを出しているんです
ホルモンのせいだと言わないでください
だったら私の頭もおかしくなるはずでしょ
いろんなものを見ると
今は年だからしょうがないかも
若い時あったんだから
で 私はもうだいたいかなり明るく元気でいるんだからね
女の人っていうのは明るい人には惹かれますよ
だから感じます あの女はなんかちょっと変なことを考えているんだとかね
で 客観的に見ると まあ結構美人なんですね
でも私のホルモンは変わりません
やはり心は変わらないんだからね
あの女は矢倉なんでも綺麗でしたねとか
後で思い出すこと全くないんです
だからまず心 それから物体
一般の人は心の管理ないんだから
きれい美人と思った途端
体にこの信号が入っちゃって変化が起きるんですね
そこでホルモンまで出ちゃうと
もう奴隷でロボットでやることやるんですね
それからどんなトラブルが起きても気にしないバカになっちゃうんです
自分の奥さんにバレたりしてとかね
家族は不幸になったりとか
仕事をクビになったりと
一回あったでしょ NHK
の 2回ぐらいあったんですね
なんかあれ なんていいます？痴漢
知識人でしょ それは気にしない
その瞬間で 後で悩んだっても
もう終わりですね 話は
そこでお釈迦様がそこら辺
この根本的な この感情
本能と当たってみてください
自由になりたければ このステージなく成り立たないんです
自由なる道が だから最初のレッスンは戒の道徳ですね
儀式的に戒律を守るのではなく
自分は真理に従う正しい生き方を励んでいるのだという自覚が必要です
例えば 今日 皆様に無理やり強引に読ませた五戒あるでしょ
あれは無理やり儀式で守った意味じゃないんです
これは正しい生き方 これで自分の弱みと闘っているんだと理解しながら
道徳的な生き方をするんです
そこで道徳的な生き方をした時点で
結構自由になるんです
例えば盗むことをする
盗むの形いろいろあるでしょ
昔はもう一番原始的な盗みというのは
人の家に入って何か金を持っていくことでしょうね
あるいはカバンをパクっていく程度でしょ
でももっと精密な盗みがいっぱいありますね
会社の会計の場合は数字をあちらこちらに入れたりとか
いろいろ精密な盗みがあります
はい 盗みをした時点から自分がやばいでしょう
いつバレるかわからないんだから
自由がなくなっているんです
嘘をついてみてください
人を嘘をついて黙った時点から
自分の自由がなくなっているんです
大変です それから ね みんなね
男たちは自分の奥さんに嘘を言うでしょ
自由がなくなるんです
その時点から だから この面白いです
ブッダがいきなり自由の道を教えているんです
修行になる道を教えているんです
だから 何か戒律を守ってみると
皆様は戒律は面倒くさいと思うでしょ？戒律を守ると
それが束縛だと思っているでしょ
それは本能での気持ちなんですね
本能が 自分の煩悩が言っている言葉なんです
だから そこを戦うんですね
戦ってみたら その方が自由ということがわかるんです
2番目サマーディ サマ... 2番目の学問
だからこの戒の学校もかなりの大きいんでしょう
一日で卒業できません
戒という学校に入って卒業したら
次 定 サマーディを日本語で定と書きますけど
定めという感じでね 精神統一
乱れた心で生きることでは成長の見込みはない
精神統一で喜悦を経験する
精神的に統一して落ち着いていると結構自由です
例えば友達三人で仲良く何かやっている
二人がその間で何とかでぶつかっちゃって
どんどん話が進んじゃって
喧嘩する羽目にもなっちゃって
感情的になって 何だお前
なんでそんなこと でも自分がすごく落ち着いているならば
自分が自由です 自分の感情に乗っちゃって混乱したら終わり
だからどんな場合でも
大きな問題を抱えている時とかね
国の予算を作らなければいけないとか
精神的に落ち着いているとすごく軽く楽なんです
物事の判断できるようになる
困ることはなくなる そこでお釈迦様はこれを進んでしっかりと精神統一だけ学んでみて
そうすると この細胞たちからすごくこのエンドルフィンを出してね
すごく体が楽になるんです
すごく楽しくなるんです
それでなおさら難しいことを学ぼうというところに行くんです
3番目 それは智慧なんですね
これ 三学の3番目 サンはパンニャーと言うんで智慧です
だから智慧は最後の学問だからね
結構順番があります 落ち着いた心で生きることを観察します
それは世の中で誰もやらないことなんですね
いきなり私は神様が私を創ったと信じて
その神様のテキスト通りに生きるだけ
生きるとは何ぞやと誰も見ないんです
何だこの命はとかね 明確に客観的に観察します
観察する能力を徐々に上げなくてはいけません
あの仏教はすごい自分自身を宿題にやるんです
自分自身を勉強しなさいと
難しくないでしょ 百科事典買う必要もないし
本買う必要もないし 自分を勉強するんだから
それで観察してしてみてくださいと
命の構成を順番で発見していくんです
そうすると観察していくと
あ 命ってこういうものであると
だから実験台は自分です
宿題は自分自身なんです
神でも誰でもない 不動明王がいるのかどうかね
という宗教あるでしょ？呪文唱えながら不動明王を経験したくて
だから変なことをやると頭が壊れますから
弘法大師みたいにね なんかなんか変な怒りとか見えたりするでしょ
まあそんなね もう五 六年瞑想しなくても
約バットね  1本で あの
秒秒でできますよ 光見ることはね
だからそんな難しくないんです
これまたいろんな南無妙法蓮華経と唱えたり
南無阿弥陀仏を唱えたりして
もう誰かを体験しようとするんですね
そんなのは精神的に病気になる道で
自由になる道じゃないんです
だからこの観音様を念じると言ったら
宿題は向こうにあるんですね
阿弥陀さんを念じる場合は
自分には経験ないんですね
だから経験しても それは本物かどうか分かりませんだからね
で これでブッダは問題解決しています
自分を研究しなさい 自分がいつだって完璧にいますからね
トイレに入ろうか ご飯食べていようか
電車に乗っていようが
自分全部持っていくでしょ
自分自分自身も会社に行くと
要らない部品を家に置いておく
それはしませんね 全部そのまま持っていくんだから
会社に 会社から飲み屋さんに行く場合は全部持っていくんです
だからどこにいても自分フルセットでいるんですね
お風呂に入る時でも 自分自身フルセットでお風呂に入るんです
じゃあやっぱり右足を置いておきましょうとかはできないね
突然が暖かくなっちゃうとね
ちょっと真相に負担ですから
じゃあ真相を部屋に置いておいて
お風呂に入るとかできないでしょ？フルセットで行くんで
だから自分自身を研究しなさいとお釈迦様は言うんです
そこでこの自分自身どのようになっているのかということは徐々に見えて
発見する真理を省略すると
すべて膨大な量だから
項目をいくつ二つだけ紹介します
命は体 物質と心 感覚 組織という二つで成り立っています
まず自分を二つに割れます
2種類が 合わせているんです
それは観察しなくてできない
例えば 40兆の細胞があって
その外に感覚があるわけじゃないんです
40兆の細胞そのものに感覚があるんです
だから普通は分解 区別することはできない
ブッダの観察すると あ
これ働きが二つである
物質があって感覚があると
これは知恵の第1ステージで
ナムルパリチェンジャーのとパーリ語では言うんです
物質は因縁によって瞬間瞬間変わっていく
物質はもう変わる 変わる変わる
同じ空気を 2回吸えないでしょ？同じ水を 2回飲めないでしょ
変わる変わる 変わる変わる
体のね 90%ぐらい水ですけど
同じ水じゃないでしょ
心も対象によって瞬間瞬間変わっていく
で 心はね 例えば目で見るということは心なんですね
で 目を動かすたびに心が変わるんです
だって全部見えるんだから
変わらなかったら見えません
例えばこのテーブルを見てください
花見えると心が変わる
このパソコンの後ろしか皆さん見えませんだけど
これ見るとまた変わる
テーブルまた変わる マイクロフォンを見るとまた変わる
皆様の目にこのコードやらマイクロフォングループやら花
パソコン あれ全部見えるでしょ？真ん中に立ってる見たくはない
私見るでしょ だからそれは区別できますね
だからそこは心が変わって変わって変わっていくんです
例えば 私はこうやって手を動かすと
皆さんも見えるでしょ
皆さんの心がそれと合わせて変わっていくんです
でないと見えませんよ
だから物質よりも激しく心が変わると変わるんだと
この観察する人は発見します
人の心じゃなくて自分の心
人の体ではなくて自分の体
したがって自分という現象は瞬間瞬間変わっていくと発見します
私っていうのは瞬間瞬間違う私だよと
じゃあ分かりやすくします
このホールに入った時の私
皆様方ですかね 今いるのは
同じ私 同じ体 同じ感覚
同じ気分 違うでしょ もう別人でしょ
自分とは瞬間的な現象です
それを観察で発見します
この 3番目の学問だからね
智慧の学問 それで発見しますよ
実体ではない命という何かないんだと
発見します 自分がいる
実在するという錯覚 そこで何かひらめいちゃうんです
今まで錯覚で生きていたんだと
自分がいるということは錯覚だよと
感覚組織の中に多数の感情が流れています
仏教では煩悩と言います
例えば 花を見ただけじゃないんです
花を見た瞬間で感情も生まれるんです
これセットで生まれないわけじゃないんです
欲 怒り 嫉妬などの感情があるから
変わらない自分がいるという錯覚が生じるんです
このなんで錯覚が起こるのかというと
この感情のせいなんです
例えばある人を見て怒る
怒る 怒ったっていう感情がそのまま変化しながが続く
続くんだから 私がいる
私がこの人のことを怒っているという風になっちゃうんです
これは錯覚です あの瞬間で怒ったんだけど
その人出て行ったら怒る必要ないんです
その人は部屋に出てまた戻ったら怒る必要ないんです
その人はまた違う人間だから
怒ってもいいんだけど
我々は怒り 欲など感情がずっと持っていくんだから
回転しながら自我という錯覚が生まれるんです 1500
の感情も瞬間瞬間変化していく現象です
感情は1500ぐらいあります
あの 皆様に 1500学んでくださいと言ってないんですからね
貪瞋痴に 3つにしているんです
まあ実は私も1500覚えてないんです
まあテキストは持っています
質問だったらさっさとテキスト持ってきて教えますけどね
命は瞬間で現れて消えていくから
命に対して愛着がなくなります
これ省略でしょう 観察すると
こういう風に皆様誰だって進んでいきます
例えば怒っても瞬間に
例えば何か食べようと口に入れたら
味がまずい あ まずい 嫌ということになる
それ口から出すか飲み込んでな
まあその気持ちは悪い
それであーまずかった
なんでまずいのか 後で悩んじゃうと
自分がこの感情を続けていくんです
噛んだ 噛んでみた時 まずかっただけで
飲み込んだらもうまずくないんですもう
だから皆様にはまずいものは食べられないんですね
私には食べられます 瞬間だけ頑張ればいいんだからね
それからどうったことない
はい 自分というのはこのイナズマより早く消えるんだったら
自分に愛着する馬鹿がいないでしょう
私を守らなくてはどうやって守る？じゃあイナズマを
あ きれい あ これずっとあってほしいと
できる？できるわけないでしょ
あれは花火を見たら大空ドーンとドカンと広かってきれいですね
はい それ止めてもらってください
なんて美しい形でしょうか
できる？できるわけないでしょ
だから欲が生まれても
なんできれいですかと
瞬間に捨てください あー終わっちゃったと
来年も見ようとはやめてください
来年あなたいないんです
来年は別人が虫化すると見るかも
はい それではあの 今私はこの悟りのあるステージ説明してよるかっていう
悟りのね よるかに悟りは4段階で送ります
智慧っていうのは難しいんですよ
卒業するためには4回やらなくちゃいけないんです
そこでパーリ経典でよくある言葉があるんです
ヤンキンチ サムデ ダンマン サッバンタン ニロダ ダンマンという言葉は分かったら
その人は預流果に悟っているんです
長いフレーズですけども省略しましたね
ヴィレジャン ヴィータマウン ダンマ チャックン ウデパーディ ヤンキンチ サムデ ダンマン サッバンタン ニロ
ダ ダンマンと言っているというある文章です
意味は因縁によって起こる現象はすべて滅するのですと
花火と同じです 花火は大空でものすごくでっかく
現れるんですね いわゆる小さな火薬
燃えるだけ 火薬にある物質によって赤くなったり
黄色くなったり 白色 白色になったりするだけ
まあ三原色以外は作れませんだからね
だから原因ででしょ 火薬が燃えた瞬間で火薬終わりでしょ
だからそちらに真理があるんです
原因によって生まれたものは必ず消える
必ず消える では 原因がなく何か生まれる？ありえないんです
何一つも原因なく生まれません
だったらすべて必ず消える
そこは発見したら これは自分で発見しなくちゃいけないので
その人が預流果に達しているというのです
もう自由を獲得したんです
で あの言葉通りに訳すると
起こる性質のすべては滅する性質があるというふうに
言葉通りに訳すると リテラルトランスレーションと英語で言うんです
上書いたのは日本語の訳なんです
2行目で書いたのはリテラルトランスレーション
言葉に合わせて日本語の言葉を入れたんです
で パーリ語はそうやってちょっと精密に単語を使うんですよ
起こる性質のすべてに滅する性質があるという
預流果がこの事実真理を自ら発見します
ブッダの教えは因縁の教えです
ブッダは因縁を教えたんです
はい そういうことで ちょっと因縁について持ってきます
皆様方 因縁発見したら
もう皆様が主人です 自由です
もう感情で操れません
人に私はどうすればいい？と聞く必要なくなっちゃうんです
もう少し英語単語なんですけど
コンディショナリティーというんですね
コンディションという皆様が知っている単語なんですね
ちょっと専門的な意味で使っています
因縁性ですね 訳すると
今ここにある現象は 今ここだけの現象です
ちょっと難しいね 時間と場所が変わったら
今の現象がなくなって別な現象に変わります
例えば 今皆様方座っていらっしゃるでしょ
立った途端 場所が変わったね
時間変わったね 皆様も変わったんです
だから現象というのはその瞬間だけなんです
例えば皆様にこの花見えるでしょ？皆様方はこちらに花があると誤解しているんだけど
実はそうじゃないんです
この光が当たって反射して目にずっと触れているから
この画像が頭の現れるんです
ちょっとずれたら違う画像になるんです
光変わったら違う画像になるんです
この物体変えたらまた違うがそれになるんです
だからコンディショニングってそういうことでかなり大変なんです
この瞬間だけ 人が本当にすごい可愛くニコッと微笑んだら
皆様方すごく喜び感じるんですね
それで ああ この人いいですね
可愛いですねと執着を持っていくでしょ？アウト
アホです あの瞬間だけなんです
場所が変わると その人は可愛く微笑んだっていうこともわからない
自分が見てる角度 私は時々子供たち付き合ってますから
ある角度で見るとすごい可愛く見えるんですね
それは角度を変えて見るんです
可愛くない だから感情で持っていると
ずっと可愛い可愛いということになって
変な幻覚の世界になるんです
集中した心で客観的に現象を観察すると発見できる真理です
いわゆる今ここの現象は今ここだけです NOWANDHERE
だからNOWということ
今ということはすぐ変わるでしょ
ここで場所もすぐ変わっちゃうでしょ
集中してみると これが見えてくるんです
コンディション コンディショナリティーということ
正しく生きるとは 今の瞬間の原因に合わせることです
大げさなプログラムじゃないんです
今の瞬間に合わせるだけ
例えば 自分に皆様の目の前にごちそうがあると
反応はじゃあ食べようという反応でしょ
ごちそう誰かちょっと持っていったら
であれ変えなくちゃいかんですね
そこで煩悩ある人は食べたかったのに
もう持っていかれたんだからと悩むんですね
真理知ってる人は目の前に食べ物があって
食べようという気持ちが生じて
その食べるものの場所が動いたんだから
今ないんだから 今その気持ちはない
楽ちん 頭イカれてる人がこの場所をずれてるのに
反応だけずれてない  これは相当変なんです
こう...ちょっと別な例えましょう
例えば自分が飼っている猫がいて
あ かわいいかわいいと頭を撫でたくなっちゃって
まあその場所 猫はかわいがって欲しがっているならば
頭を撫でてあげてもいいんだけど
でも 自分が手を持っていると猫が嫌がっちゃっているならば
それでは無理やり撫でる必要あるんですかね
あるいは手を伸ばして触ろうと思ったら
猫がいるということで
触る瞬間で猫が出て行っちゃって
もうそちらに何か別なものがあったとしましょう
毒蛇がいたりしましょう
それでも触る？あの反応も変えた方がいいんです
だからあなたの反応はその瞬間だけにしてくださいなんです
それは訓練上でなり得る能力であって
ただ考えただけでできることじゃないんです
だから私の話を聞きながら
別れた振られた恋人のことを思うバカもいるでしょ
あるいは 5年前死んだお母さんのことで悩むアホもいるでしょ
みんなアホなんです 反応はその瞬間だけです
そうすると抜群に能力が現れてくるんです
はい それでポイントに入ります
随所 それなんです 随所っていうのは
だからもうすごい偉いでしょう
瞬間瞬間に反応して終わり
その反応正しい いつでも
だから自分が主人なんですね
それからそれこそ真理なんです
誰でも今の状態 条件 因縁に反応して生きているんです
我々も今の条件に反応しているんです
嫌になったり 楽になったり
落ち込んだり怒ったりするのは
環境に対する自分の反応なんです
じゃあ私は今 悟った人の態度を説明してたでしょ
でも我々悟ったに 私たちもちゃんと反応してるでしょ
そのその瞬間に 今誰も歌って踊ってやろうと思ってないでしょ
この場ではその反応はダメですね
やってないんですね ぴったり反応してるんじゃない
この反応で自分自身が硬い存在になったり
環境に依存して環境に操れるロボットになります
操られる 操られる だから
我々も反応するんだけど
なんか硬くなってロボットになるんです
例えば今 テーブルの上に花があるでしょ？反応してるでしょ
これ変わったら皆様が何やるのかと思っちゃうんですね
じゃあこちらに置いとく
皆様変やと思うでしょ？操られているんです
別に何が悪いんですか？ここで必ずしもこちらに置かなくちゃいけない
誰が決めたんですか？もうわかった
この花に操られていたこと
そのまま固定したくなったでしょ？今も心の中で元に戻せと
もし私は元に戻そうと思ってるでしょ
どうしてもこれはちょっと落ち着かないなと
反応はしているんだけど
何か変なんです 操られているんです
感情に それがない 悟った人にとっては
あ そう 我々  ですから  2つの反応があるんです
環境に反応することで自由が失う
に 環境に適応することで主になる
森林になるという 2つの反応があるんです
皆様が環境に反応することで自由が失われているんです
操られるんです 真理に出した人が環境に反応します
それで自由になっているんです 2
つ理解してください 私は環境を破壊すると言ったでしょう
例えば このホールは今
空気を暖めているんですね
これは環境に反応しているわけじゃなくて
自分で環境を破壊している
自分の好みで だからありのままではなく
あってほしいまま 外から入ると暖かくなってほしいと思っているんですね
だから生命は環境に反応してなくてあってほしいという気持ちがあって
それに合わせてして合わせない場合はすごく苦労するんです
例えば 今日 このエアコンディショニングシステムが壊れたならば
皆様言いたい放題悪口を言うんです
困るんです 皆様は この建物を管理する人々は困ってないんだけど
皆様が困るんです 悩むんです
なんでそれ修理していないんでしょうかと
あれやこれやとかね これも公の場所だからね
その連中は何やってるのかと
なんでそういうふうになるんですかね
あってほしいままということで環境に適応するんだから
それは正しくないんです
主人公になってないんです
はい もうちょっと詳しくいきましょう
幻覚に迷う生き方  1の反応は幻覚に迷い
迷う生き方 自分がいるという錯覚を持って環境に適応しても
それはありのままに見るのではなく
自分の主観 好み 期待 希望を環境に被って見ることです
皆様方は環境に自分の主観を被っているんです
見ていないんです えっ
被せて 女の人を化粧するような感じで
世間に化粧した仮面を見せているんです
だから被せるものっていうのは
自分の期待 例えば花を入れたとする
それで自分がイメージ
を作ってそれかぶせるんですね
イメージ通りの羽にならなかったら
なんか悲しいね イメージ通りに咲かなかった
悲しい 料理作る 自分のイメージをかぶせているんです
イメージ通りにならなかったら
結構トラブっちゃうんです
だから世界は私のイメージ通りに動いてくれる
私の期待通りに動いてくれる
そもそも私という錯覚があるから問題でしょ
主観を これ何て言ったっけ？破れた
ん？ん あ うん 主観をかぶらす
かぶせた  かぶせた 現実は自分の希望通りになるはずはない
自分の主観をかぶせたからといって
現実はそうならない だから我々は現実をいじめなくちゃいけないんです
破壊しなくちゃいけないんでしょ
それでも自分より世界は巨大です
必ず負けるんです 主人になれない
なんかアリ１匹がこの建物をちょっとかじって壊してやろうと思っていることなんです
アリ1匹にはできません
あの木材はシロアリ食べるでしょ
では シロアリ1匹だけ持って連れてきてください
何かできるかと あ これ噛んでやろうと思うかもしれませんんだけど
噛んでもどうったことないんです
シロアリ1匹だから だからシロアリ1匹程度の私は
世界が私の希望通りになろうと思うと楽しいね
幸福ですね それはだからそこで自作ですごい苦しみを作ってます
環境を強引に壊すか 負けて惨めに悩み苦しみに陥るかという結果になります
だから我々の因果法則はわからないし
物事は今ここしかないというコンディショナリティ
因縁性 理解していないからひどい目に遭っているんです
環境を壊しても結果は悩み苦しみです
では 環境を壊すことができたとしましょう
でも結果はそれでも悩み苦しみなんです
えーと 時間的にはもう皆様クタクタ疲れていると思いますけどね
別に私は疲れてないんだからね
大丈夫です これ一発でいった方がいいと思います
人は因縁法則を無視して
自分の主観的なプログラム
設計図を持って世界でね
これちょっと間違い 生きようとしています
これは一般人が通常ではないんです
自分のプログラムを持ってるんです
変です 瞬間の自分しかいないのに
自分の設計図を持ってるんです
持って 世界はその通りでなければ壊すんです
いくら努力しても 思考を駆使しても
研究しても ありのままの現実を発見できません
そんなことになったら
ずっと設計図を持って調べてもありのままに見えません
主観的なプログラムで世の中を見ても
ありのままに見えません
あの日本の国内旅行 旅行はどうやって？旅行会社は旅行を宣伝するときは
派手に泊まるホテルのディナーの写真を出してるんですね
なんだか牛肉は食べたい
食べ放題とかね なんとかのワインは食べ飲み放題とかね
そこで最初からもう設計図を上げてるんです
せっかく北海道に行っても
北海道を見ないで ホテルの中であの食い物牛のように食っちゃって寝て帰るだけ
何の意味もないんで旅行
私も日本の皆様と一緒に時々あのガイド旅行とかするんだけど
このこの間タイとかミャンマーと案内兼ガイドする人はいつでも今日はなんだらかんだらホテルで泊まります
そのホテルではこういう食べ物をこういう食べ...もう首を絞めたくなるんですね
ずーっとその説明 朝バスに乗ったらまた朝ごはんの説明と
まあ着物でしょう みんな
旅行に行ったんだから
その瞬間 その瞬間変化する世界を見ればどうですかね
バスの窓から人々を見たら
違う生き方をしている人々でしょうに
あんまりも見るものはいっぱいあるのに見ない
主になるのではなく 奴隷
ロボットのままです この設計図を持っているんだから
しかし 環境に因縁に反応はしています
ロボットたちも環境に反応しているんだけど
主になっていないんです
心理の世界じゃないんです
妄想の世界 自分がいるという錯覚の世界で生きているんです
はい 2番目に行きます
主なる心理の世界 これ2番目
ある人は客観的に無実に自分を観察する
自我がないと成り立たないと発見する
自分がないから自分のプログラムも設計図もないのです
自分がないんだからプログラムないんです
変化する環境に 現象の流れに
ありのままに正しく反応するんです
何のことなくやるべき反応するだけ
自分でもうちょっと高い方がいいんじゃない？は出てこないんです
もうちょっと小さい方がいいんじゃないかって出てこないんです
じゃあ今更これ見取り戻します
だから例えばこれを見てもうちょっと背が高い花だったらいいのにとかね
はないんです この袋がない方がいいんじゃない？
自分がない場合は設計図はないんです
だから環境を破壊する必要はないし
環境によって自分が困る
悩むこともないんです
主なる真理の世界 風が吹くと枝が揺れる
風のエネルギーと枝の力の見事なバランスなんです
どんな程度で揺れるのかと
もう完璧に調和しているんです
風は力を与えているんだけど
枝も力を持ってるし それでちょうど引き算足し算で揺れ具合は決めます
誰も困りません 枝に自我がないでしょ
自分の好み プログラムもない
自分の好みのプログラムもない
自分の好みもない 枝がこういうふうに揺れたいんだけど
こういうふうに揺れたくないとかね
ないでしょ だから 吹く風と枝が見事に調和して仲良くなんです
自分の錯覚をなくした人こそ
正しく環境に反応するんです
例えば 預流果に悟った人は
自我の錯覚を発見した人が
ものすごい環境と仲良しなんです
お互いに邪魔しないんです
それでやっと主人になったんです
その人は自由です 主です
変化する環境に悩み 苦しみを作ることはできません
しませんではなくて その人を悩みすることは不可能です
苦しませることは不可能です
はい そういうことで 仏教ではあの
あの禅の公案で五 六で言っていることは
本当は悟り 解脱のことなんです
終始に主となる 自我の錯覚は無明
無知です 錯覚が破ることは智慧です
智慧がある人は真理に達しています
何にも依存しないので自由で主です
自分が 無常 苦 無我を発見した人です
あの禅のフレーズの意味はこういう風になるんです
だから主ですと またそれが真理ですと言ったでしょ
なんだこれはと わからないでしょ
短いフレーズで 解説すると
そんな風にすごい長い説明になります
はい 自由になる道 釈尊の教えを理解して実践で体験することです
解脱へという山岳を進むことです
それで自由になるんです
あの禅五六で言っている通りになります
はい それで話は終了です
あの先ほどプロジェクターの画面で智慧を発見するという画面がありましたが
その五番 五番目にはのその智慧を発見する智慧というのは
命の構成を順々に発見することという風に書いたんですが
これはあの この前 昨年ちょうど同様にありましたけれども
十二因縁のことを言っているのではないかなと思うんですけども
お釈迦様がなんかお経読みますと
悟りを開いた後 なんか木の下で 1週間にわたって十二因縁を順逆に見たとというお経があるんですけれども
そこで質問はその十二因縁の項目の中に
同じく今日のお話にあった自我の錯覚というんですか
自我ですね という項目は表面的に見る限りないんですけれども
自我の錯覚というのは
一番最初にあるアヴィッチャーとともに生まれるんでしょう
それともアヴィッチャーの後にサンターラとかナーマーラとか続きますけども
その アビッチャーじゃなくて
どこで生まれるのか マーラっていうんですか？マーラはどこで生まれるのかを知りたいんだけど
うん えーと 十二因縁でね
あれですね 苦しみがどうやって終わりなく続くのかというテーマで語られるものだから
あの全て入ってない 入ってはいるんだけどね
ちょっとめんどくさいんですね
例えば無明があるとは自我っていうこと
自我の錯覚イコール無明なんですね
だからこれ あの自我の錯覚というのはちょっと俗っぽい話になるんだから
これはお釈迦様にとっては真理の思考だから
無明という人と関係なく
この現象だけ取り上げているんですね
いわゆる心にある無明という状態があると
だから無明という状態ある心が
現実には自我の錯覚で活動しているんで
自我の錯覚で言ったら
これちょっと大きくなっちゃうんですね
小さな項目に切ってみているんですね
だから無明 アビッチャー
ヴァッチャー サンカーラ
サンカーラは衝動ですね
衝動が自我がなければまた生まれないしね
だから次 渇愛という言葉があるんですね
感覚からヴェーダナー
アヴァッチャー タンハーと
そちらにははっきりと新たな自我が生まれてくるところなんですね
感覚から渇愛が生じると
自我がなければ渇愛は生じませんね
だからまあ自我特別に出してないんだけど
十二因縁の中に全部入っているんです
錯覚ですから 無明でしょう
イコール無明でしょう
はい  はい 次 この方に すいません
マイクを回していただけます
えーと 功徳 功徳と解脱の関係について質問なんですけども
いつも大滝精舎で瞑想会の後に回向の文を唱え唱えていまして
その最後に積まれた功徳によって解脱解脱が得られますようにという
そういう文言があるんですけども
功徳を積むことで解脱が得られるというのはどういうことか
ご説明をお願いいたします
それはちょっと難しいな
功徳っていうのは この自分の感情
煩悩 本能を戒める行為であると知って思っちゃうと
功徳は解脱につながります
功徳を積んで幸せになってやりそうと思ったら
これは煩悩欲ですね だからそういう 2つの面を持っています
そこでややこしい 功徳を積んでないと
能力のある人間として
生命として生まれません
悪を犯しちゃうと不幸
不幸な次元に生まれるんだから
解脱の見込みは一切ないんです
苦毒を積んで人間界に戻っ...生まれて
しっかり物事を考える人間に考えられる人間にならなくちゃいけない
だから 功徳があった方が悟れる環境を作られるっていうこともある
功徳なしにならない なりに成り立ちません
しかし 人間が無明で功徳を積んで幸福になりそうと思っちゃうと
これは輪廻転生を残すだけの話になっちゃうんですね
そういういくつかの側面があると理解してください
功徳を積むことが自分の本能と戦うことであると
本能は悪行為したいというところで
功徳を積む人は直接 直接的に解脱に繋がっているんです
もっと俗っぽく言えば
智慧でもって功徳を積むか
ただ単に誰もやってるから功徳を積むかっていうよね
マンネリでマンネリで功徳積んでも輪廻は延びますけど
解脱に達するか否かよくわからない
智慧 智慧で智慧と一緒に功徳を積む人は
その功徳は全部解脱のエネルギーになります
はい 以上です  すみません
あの功徳とその善行っていうのは同じ意味ですか？ 同じですね
ちょっと微妙な差がありますけどね
あの 功徳っていうのは
一般的な行為で完成することはできません
善行為っていうのは完成することはできます
それだけ  すみません あの
功徳と善行 良いカルマ
あの 功徳と良いカルマ
カルマ  善行 ちょっと単語違いますね
パーリ語でプンヤとクサラと言うんですね
クサラって直訳すると巧みという意味になるんです
だから巧みに生きること
善行為なんです 巧みに生きることは完成できます
完成してたら悟ってるんで
功徳っていうのは こうむことの行為な
お布施する 人を助ける
完成できませんね 一つも
いつでもリミットがあるんです
あの すいません あのえっと
カルマでカルマ カンマ
うん 業 良い業 善 善行意味ですか
と 功徳は同じ意味です
まああの善行 全て業 善行に入ります
ありがとうございます
はい あと何？えーと じゃあちょっとまたそちらに行きますので
えっと あの体に痛みがある時に
体と心は別のものだと教えてはいただいたんですが
すぐに心で感情でダメだなとか落ち込んだりしますけれども
痛みがあるその時は感情を混ぜずに
その痛みに気づくということをすればいいのでしょうか？ うん
その通りです 失敗しますけど
頑張ればできるようになります
あの体に痛みないんです
体物質だからね 痛いのは心の方なんです
じゃあ痛みを細かく自分で見ていくということなんで
そうですよ だから痛みがあると
あ 嫌だな もうこんななと思うのは自分のプログラムでしょ？自分の好みがあるんですね
痛みは嫌ですと それに合わせて現実は痛みを感じているんですね
そこで嫌になって負けちゃうんですね
それ再び再び再びやってみると
痛み 痛みと観察することはできます
ありがとうございます
あの 今の世の中は やはり自己を自分
自我の意識でもってこの社会を作ってきたと思うんです
人間は ですから 今このような状況になって
特に日本はお金第一ですし
人の気持ちを無視するような社会になっているわけなんですけれども
そしてその中で あの まあえっと
若い人が政治的にいろんなあの
あの立ち上がったりとか
ミーチューなども運動なども起きて
少しでも良くしようという人もいるんです
いると思うんですね そして
このなんか悪魔的な社会だなと
今日本もなってしまったから
それはタイとか それこそスリランカのお国のようにとは全く違ってしまって
そこであの なんとかしたいなって人もいると思うんですけれども
そういう 世俗的な道徳と
本当に真に真に悟った人とか
仏教の倫理っていうのは全く違うものなんでしょうか
というのは お釈迦様も昔の時代ではすごく画期的なことをなさってたんじゃないかと思うんですよね
そのお釈迦様も一つの運動体を作ったと思うんですけども
今のこの社会の中での運動体っていうのは
先生から見ると そういう仏教の倫理の面から見ると
どういうふうな評価をなさるのか
やはり自分の主観のプログラムによる運動体しかないっていうふうに見られるんでしょうか
うん まあ人々はね みんなまあちゃんと観察しない限りは真理を発見しないんだからね
それはそれだけですね
私の反応は まあ別に自分がプログラム持ってないんですね
だから世の中のことを見て
なんだこりゃと思うこと全くないしね
今おっしゃった通りに
悪魔的な存在 自分の国でもありますよ
わずかな何人かが真面目に修行するんであってね
全体的に政治家の説法を聞いてるだけです
みんな悪魔よりひどいんです
日本人は政治家の話を聞いてないんだからね
その点でマシですよ だから仏教を教えやすいんです
日本では こんな宗教大反対っていう皆様の間でね
説明しやすいんです まあまあ
その世の中はそういうことだからね
どうしても破壊 破滅へ進むんですよ
それは一人一人が頑張ってもね
真理を発見しない限りは
まあ世界は現れては消える
もう破壊へ進んでいく
いつでも矛盾でしょう
経済的に成長すると自然破壊をする
自然破壊するとみんなに生きることは苦しくなる
そうするとさらに金がかかる
するとさらに経済成長しなくちゃいけないとかね
まあ悪循環になるんですね
だからそれははっきり言えば
これ環境を壊すことでしょ
だから人間でなかったら
この地球はものすごくそのままでしょ
動物はほんのわずかしか環境破壊しないんですね
自分が生きられる範囲で
生きるために必要な範囲でしか環境破壊しないんですね
チーターは足が速いからといってね
走って走ってみるみる獲物を殺せませんね
ヘビは猛毒を持っているんだから
誰でも殺されますよと言ってね
あちらこちら隠れて動く動く動物を噛んで殺すことはしません
生きるために最低限必要な獲物を食べているんですね
だから動物も破壊しますけど
あまり地球規模では痛くない
回復もない破壊なんに
人間の破壊はそうじゃないんですね
恐ろしい程度で破壊する
例えば日本人 日本の国に輸入する魚の量っていうのは
なんか国の大きさと人口には全く合わないぐらい大量なんですね
地球の全魚のあれ収穫のまあ 4分の1程度ぐらい取ってるみたいだから
そんな食べてるようにも気がしませんだけど
ようわからないんですね
世界のウナギは全部日本人一人で買っていって食べてるでしょ
それで世界でウナギが絶滅するなってるんだと
日本人だけ食べて だからなんかね
そうやってこの自分のプログラムで動くんだから
いろんなことが起こるんですね
まあそれだけね それはまあ我々にはもう我々
だから唯一の答えは自分自身で真理を発見しなさいなんですね
あの人類が真理を発見しなさいと言ったっても
これはちょっとやってくれませんよ
みんな しかし ブッダの悟りにおいて
ブッダの日常生活の生き方
あの講演喋る前に私は言ったでしょ
親子関係でね だからブッダが親っていうのは師匠であると言ったんだから
それやれば 子供の最初の師匠になれば
自分の能力でここで卒業ってあるでしょ
それから小学校で次の師匠が入りますからね
バトンタッチしますからね
だからそういう風にブッダのそれだけの教えを見ても
親子関係の問題は消えるんです
だからあの悟りはもう別世界ですけど
お釈迦様は俗世間に喋ったとこでも人類を実行した方がいいとは思いますよ
ブッダの教えに従えば
世界平和に世界平和が成り立ちます
そうでない限りは この連中はもうお互い殺し合いはやめません
テロ行為はなくならないんです
実際はブッダの言葉は全てに答えなんですね
でもそれを代わりに神を信じるんですね
まるっきりおかしいんだけど
まあそういうことだからね
世界は うん それだけです
私の反応は あまりよくわからなかったがね
聞いているんでしょうかと
よくあの俗世間の道徳っていうのは全く当てにならないものだっていうふうにも思えるっていうことなんだなって
今聞いてと思いました
うん まあまあ 道徳がないと社会は成り立たないんですね
俗世間の道徳 俗世間はそれ認めないんですね
だから道徳がないと社会ってソサエティ成り立たないんです
一人で森の中で生活しても
自分自身に対する道徳を持たないと死んじゃいますよ
早くも だから道徳は純粋に何ぞやと
これを心理学的に科学的に発見することは
ブッダの教えしかないんですね
キリスト教も嘘をつくなよ
人違いにしなさいと言ってるんだけど
あれは正しい道徳じゃなくて
神がそう言ったと モーセスにそう言ったと
よく歴史学者調べると
モーセスというのは存在しなかったキャラなんですね
誰かが作った だから神が言ったということも嘘になっちゃうでしょ
だから神が言わなかったら
隣人憎んでもいいんですかね
だから神野郎が言っても言わなくても
人類お互い愛した方がいいでしょうに
だから言ってることはなんか間違ってないんだけど
正しくもないんです だからイエスにしたっても
神がいようがいなかろうが関係なく
汝らは生命を愛しなさいと言った方が正しいでしょ
それは言ってないんです
だから世間の道徳っていうのは
そういう風にすごい汚れていて
不完全であんまり解脱には達しません
智慧は現れません 道徳
本物の道徳っていうのは
自分の本能と戦ってみることですね
だからちょっときついんです
しかし やる気があれば自分で勝ちますからね
自分自身の欲と戦って勝つ
自分自身の怒りと戦ってみて勝つ
...ことだから 結構気分がいいんですよ
勝利を得て 世間でまずいまずいと
バレたらまずいという
あんな腰抜け道徳じゃないんです
はい 以上です  はい それではちょうど時間となりましたので
これにて本日も講義会を終了したいと思います
はい では最後の はい これを一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッタ チェニン ドゥッカ
バヤッパッタ チェニン バヤ
ソッカッパッタ チェニン ソーカ
ホントゥ サンビ ピパニノー
はい 日本語 苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
カンティー パラマン タポーティ ティンカー ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ